There are people we are friends with for one
major but often maligned or overlooked reason:
because we were friends with them some time
ago. At one stage, it might be decades ago
now, we had a lot in common: we were both
good at maths but bad at French at school
and had a shared liking for table tennis;
or we had adjacent rooms at college and used
to help each other with assignments and commiserate
in the bar about failed dates or maddening
parents; or maybe we were interns in the same
big firm with the same (as we thought at the
time) bizarre and intemperate boss. But life
has taken us on radically different courses.
Now they’ve got three young children; they
moved to the Orkneys where they are managing
a fish farm; they’ve gone into politics
and have become a junior minister or they’re
working as a ski teacher in the Rocky Mountains.
The daily realities of our lives may be miles
apart; we may know little of their world and
they of ours. If we were introduced today,
we’d think each other pleasant enough but
would never get close. Yet it can be hugely
helpful and very redemptive to catch up with
these people, with a one-on-one dinner, a
walk in the woods or the occasional email.
These friends function as conduits to earlier
versions of ourselves that are inaccessible
day-to-day but that contain hugely important
insights. In the company of the old friend,
we take stock of the journey we have travelled.
We get to see how we have evolved, what was
once painful, what mattered or what we have
wholly forgotten we deeply enjoyed. The old
friend is a guardian of memories on which
we might otherwise have a damagingly tenuous
hold. We need old friends because of a crucial
complexity in human nature. We pass through
stages of development and as we do so, discard
previous concerns and develop a lack of empathy
around past perspectives. At fourteen, we
knew a lot about resenting our parents. Twenty
years later, the whole idea sounds absurd
and ungrateful. Yet the old friend reconnects
us with a particular atmosphere and, like
a novelist, makes us at home with a character
– ourselves – who might otherwise have
seemed impossibly alien to us. At twenty-two,
we found single life extremely painful. We
hung out a lot with a particular friend and
shared a litany of wistful, alienated thoughts.
At forty-five, with a young family around
us, we may find ourselves increasingly curious
about being single again and fantasise about
the joys of casual hook-ups. The old friend
has crucial news to impart. We experience
life from a succession of very different vantage
points over the decades, but tend – understandably
– to be preoccupied only with the present
vista, forgetting the particular, incomplete
but still crucial wisdom contained in earlier
phases. Every age possesses a superior kind
of knowledge in some area or other – which
it then, usually, forgets to hand on to succeeding
selves. Remembering what it was like not to
be who we are now is vital to our growth and
integrity. The best professors remain friends
with their past. They remember what it was
like not to know about their special topic
– and so don’t talk over the heads of
their students. The best bosses are in touch
with their own experience of starting out
as a lowly employee; the best politicians
clearly recall periods in their lives when
they held very different views to the ones
they have now formulated, which allows them
to persuade, and empathise with, hostile constituencies.
Good parents keep emotionally in touch with
the feelings of injustice and sensitivity
they had in early childhood. Kindly wealthy
people remember what it was like not to dare
to walk into a fancy food shop for fear of
being patronised. We are always better long-term
lovers if we have an avenue of loyalty back
to who we were when we first met our beloved
and were at an apogee of gratitude and modesty.
Old friends are key activators of fascinating
and valuable parts of the self that we need,
but are always at risk of forgetting we need,
in the blinkered present.
We publish new thought provoking films every week.
Be sure to subscribe to our channel and take a look at more of what we have to offer
at the link on your screen now.